trop soucieuse de son bonjour à toi
petit jeu gratuit c'est parti on l'a
jamais dit aussi vite c'est trop on
commence avec un jeu qui nous vient tout
droit du japon connais bien maintenant
le but est de manger le plus
d'ingrédients possible voilà avec une
maniabilité nul à chier comme on connaît
bien
hop là on a eu la sucette mais pas le
bas la tablette est vraiment pénètre
dans notre cour on attend la bouffe
j'aurais kiffé que soient pas et comme
je vivais encore chez ma mère quand je
joue je j'ouvre la bouche et hop la
tablette arrive à quelle mouche
dépendance n'a aucun sens attends c'est
super de l'avoir brown serait il faut le
tourner pour ensuite
olala oloma et le burger ça fait
extrêmement mauvais mélange de rajab et
ça aille la bonne si sow un plaisir
qu'est ce que ça suffit aux majors c'est
un ingrédient luminati quoi qu'il en
soit [ __ ] il se bloque aussi dans mon
cou bordel des fois tu perds tes
créations tout nous le manteau le point
soleil
oui on a mangé dans la bouche à coups de
tête dans la poiscaille en somme les
steaks a laissé gagner vous avez
toujours voulu tu votre chat devienne un
crocodile ou que votre les arts de
vienne
une chouette c'est maintenant possible
grâce à mr lost michael bay chat et par
type l'oeil alors en gros en gros
doit-on santé des animaux en d'autres
animaux bonjour j'en ai marre d'avoir un
golden retriever est ce que tu peux me
faire un singe à la place c'est une
demande que des gens font tous les jours
on vétérinaire mais ça ne marche pas
comment je sens en faisant un singe
du coup il veut modifier les oreilles
voilà ça c'est un petit coup on attend
même et c'est super dur en bref c'est
comme ça un singe non mais ça c'est les
oreilles de souris mais que ça pas du
tout vient pas de moi innocent j'attends
ce jeu car le besoin d'être con t'es pas
qu'une impression à six est tout rond si
si si mais c'est exactement pareil là
les singes ont vraiment des grosses
pattes comme s'abattant déjà d'être
calmée et qu'elles vont nous apprendre
ce métier ce qu'on aimerait c'est plus
comme ça puisque à part d'un temps les
oreilles butin avait il m'apprend au
métier c'est génial ok matin c'est le
museau qui va pas dans mes mecs mais
arrête et attendirent un chien ton truc
on dira chienne l'espace la salle serge
boîtier contenant ou tous les beaux
jours et c'est mon cochon à relais mais
j'aimerais un singe mais peut plus faire
de singe c'est parti d'un singe à
lagorce et boulot mec je lui ai fait ça
il croit que saint serge à quel moment
cet animal ressemble à ceci il est juste
un chien est allé lapointe en bo3 ou
mieux l'image en tapant scheer marron
c'est lui c'est exactement lui
regardez ça lui est ce que tu peux
transformer ma biche en cochon alors ça
c'est super sympa alors elle me dit pas
que c'est pas un cochon je te bute ce
but why à un cochon
je veux des supers ressemblance et
surtout vraiment des oreilles comme ça
va la réponse est oui
réponse est oui c'est pas un cochon que
tu veux ça s'appelle un cheval alors tu
vas dans l'écueil la plus proche de chez
toi et tu fais pas chier salut
j'aimerais que mon nounours a dit serait
plus heureuse c'est un cochon bah c'est
fou on arrête tout de suite vraiment et
voilà ça dit plus rien maintenant nous
sommes maintenant sur one night stand un
simulateur de la situation la plus
désagréable du monde se réveiller à
lendemain de soirée à côté d'une fille
dont tu te souviens même plus le nom des
acteurs hollywoodiens ma tête mon
estomac
je me sens comme un crapaud n'en soit sa
traduction hier soir qu'est ce qui s'est
passé au caire et se sont ils ouvrent
les yeux et comprendre ce qui lui arrive
il se réveille les dg en position
foetale
où est mon téléphone mais qu'est ce qui
t'es arrivé hier soir gary alors déjà
garé tu baisse d'un ton je n'ai aucune
idée mais merci de m'avoir réveiller 5%
de batteries à hautmont dieu c'est pire
qu'un jeu d'horreur sa fière de mon
téléphone passés de timbres à tence pas
ma table de nuit ça c'était pas ma
chambre
mes vêtements ils sont tous par terre je
suis complètement nu aa et oui aux mères
nées du bruit au lalalalalala ça y est
on y est là il faut garder son calme
je suppose que j'étais chanceux l'année
dernière n'en dit pas ça elle sait pas
encore retourné oms on savait pas si
c'est un gnome ou pas encore te dois de
sa chambre
oui à ces notre photo bt a totalement
chez sur tout le monde hier soir tu es
parti cherche à boire dès jamais revenu
what the fuck menant toutes les filles
était saoul et je peux pas croire que
j'ai décalé mon regard pour qu'au final
tu nous chie dessus
oh non désolé je ne suis vraiment pas de
ce qui s'est passé mais devine quoi j'ai
conclu à nouveau message
arrête de mentir un seul verre et tu
finis par conclure une meuf tu vas
devoir trouver une meilleure excuse pour
ce que tu nous as fait hier soir regard
du gari ne me croit pas il a l'air
vraiment sous les jeunes et cac prend
une photo un cachet sera obligé de me
croire comme ça voilà on fait le bilan
et notamment chaque instant pas les
décevoir
c'est super chiant ce titre que j'ai de
tout chanter si on prend une photo ce
mail à machado mais notre meilleur pote
vanot croire et nous fera pas la gueule
si on prend pas une photo notre meilleur
ami il continue nous chier dessus et on
n'est même pas sûr de rester en bons
termes avec elle quand même donc le
bilan on prend cette photo des décodeurs
voilà pour lui envoyer la photo qui va
nous répondre au nom au téléphone c'est
un c'est un sketch qu'est ce que je dois
faire la réveiller retourner dormir ou
te barrer d'ici là et là on a envie de
savoir si ces bases et avec tes à poigne
un préservatif par terre tu sais bien ce
qui s'est passé au final tu veux en
savoir plus sur la personne avec qui
s'est passé ça c'est parti d'accord en
train de faire kidnapper parfait à la
vieille pub tu parles en claquettes et
ce qu'elle vient d'envoyer la couette
sur la tête
oui on peut regarder autour de nous au
saas et son côté de la table de nuit à
la salle claude par terre c'est mauvais
signe
un tube de vaseline c'est encore plus
mauvais signe comment je me suis
retrouvé là je n'en ai aucune idée
le malaise à sachant que c'est pas
facile je c'était une bonne nuit n'en
ouais c'était cool
en passant merci ben c'est pourquoi j'ai
été à deux doigts tout est dans un taxi
de rentrer chez moi et de m'enfermer
pendant des jours dans ma chambre et je
les sauver je suis un prince charmant
suis vraiment content que tu dois
montrer tu m'as acheter à boire tu m'as
écouter et ça va vraiment fait du bien
je pense que la soirée a pris une autre
tournure grâce à toi merci s excuse
parce qu'à cause des j'ai lâché mes amis
tu peux excuser espèces d'escrocs
j'avais même pas réalisé que tu étais là
avec des amis tu ne m'as pas parler
d'eux du tout vous voulez vraiment pécho
qu à welch dans un bar avec gary pas mal
d'autres gens je pense trois petits
points
as tu penses un an ça y est elles
commencent à comprendre qu on se
souvient de rien project tu te souviens
pas vraiment ce qui s'est passé hier
soir c'est parce que tu crois allez on
prend deux mois je lui pose sur le bord
du lit on a su marquer ce que je devrais
dire je me souviens t'inquiète je me
souviens de quelques moments où je me
souviens pas du tout un grand [ __ ]
implique de gros mensonges je me
souviens de quelques trucs je suppose
que si j'avais bu autant que toi ma
mémoire doit aussi jouer des tours ouais
ça aggrave
c'est marrant oued souf je serais
vraiment effrayé de ne pas me souvenir
de quoi que ce soit après une nuit à
avons ici n'est pas parti en cachette
avant que je me réveille ou pendant que
j'étais en dehors de la chambre parce
que tu m'intéresses lucie clairement tu
as été adorable avec moi hier oui l'uci
mais partie de moi me dit qu aussitôt
réveiller tu voudrais partir maintenant
lui si je suis pas jeune homme là a tout
autant peut-être qu'on va partir sur une
relation durable à écoute on n'a pas
cherché à se faire puisque salah el hout
hier soir j'ai beaucoup parlé de moi
parle moi de toi ok alors là entretien
d'embauché mon gars c'est mon téléphone
mon ami vient juste de m'envoyer une
photo de moi nu est-ce que tu as pris
une photo de moi pendant que je dormais
ah ouais ouais
oh mon dieu tu as fait un truc pareil
c'est partout sur mon mur facebook au
nom pourquoi t'as fait ça gary [ __ ]
c'était juste pour que tu me crois tu
pas obligé de la partager les gens
m'envoient plein de sortes de messages
bizarres
je suis désolé lucie et ma famille mon
frère est sur facebook donc mes
sentiments ma dignité
ah ben je leur ai chié sur tout ça pour
prouver un mec que tu as fait l'amour
hier soir non c'est plus complexe que ça
c'est pour pour lui prouver que je lui
ment pas et que si je les plantes et
c'est pour une bonne raison
bon je suppose cela ne sauvera pas reste
ça ne sauvera pas s'il te plaît juste
dégage l'échec tu as envie de me
ramasser toutes tes merde et tu es parti
robin n'a rien dit d'autre robin est
restée dans sa chambre pendant que tu
pars tu es tu à marcher dans la rue tu
demandant comment tu allais rentrer chez
toi
c'était bizarre je me demande si les
choses auraient pu se passer
différemment en ont arrêté mais cela
n'empêche que ça se trouve génial gmail
tennis et elle l aime le water-polo sa
soja lui dire j'aime le rock et elles
aiment leur après ça ce trouve de toute
manière ça n'allait pas mal chez photo
pas photo ne me prenez pas pour des
imbéciles
ouais j'espère 27 juin sur 7,3 de dieu
gratuit j'espère souza plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à aller mais comme
d'habitude je vous souhaite de ne jamais
vous retrouver dans cette dernière
situation vraiment ce doit être
terrifiant une fois je me suis réveillé
à côté d'une huître ouverte je sais pas
si c'était passé ben j'étais terrifiée à
la 113e prochaine saison merci d'avoir
regardé portez vous bien car tout le
monde pis